She's vegetarian, she asked, 'is there any meat in this German food?'. It's all meat! That's what German's do, they just eat meat and drink beer.
Other countries always have better chip flavors than us
Smells like Lays barbecue
Smells like dirt
It's awesome but I don't know what it tastes like
I think barbecue is the right comparison
I like them
Yeah, it's delicious
They're savory, but they don't like assault your mouth
But it does't have as much flavor as barbecue
It's kind of weak
These are great, A-plus
It's non-alcoholic, get it off my table!
I mean, as a general rule, I stay away from non-alcoholic things
Malted vitamin soda, that can't be good
It smells like prune juice and beer had a baby
Smells like toast
It taste like creamier carmel soda
Sort of medicine-y
Grape juice?
It kinda tastes like beer that you've opened, left and then came back for it and left it in the sun by accident
You know what would go great with this? Alcohol
Oh!
This looks incredible
I will say though that it does look like something very human.
That is a really long piece of sausage, is that one piece of sausage?
Good?
I love it
This is bursting with flavor
That is some good sausage
Yeah, this is like what you actually should eat with beer
I don't like hot dogs, but I like this
That's German engineering at it's finest, if you ask me
Anyone who dislikes any of this is tasteless.
Isn't that a tiny tiny particle?
This looks like frosting
It's like thick, and then...
It tastes like the inside of a Ritz Bitz cracker.
It tastes like cream cheese and yogurt
Punch you in the kidney, sourness
This is not how I want to start my morning
Here darling, let me give you some salt and pepper
OK!
I like it better with the salt and pepper, yeah
You do you, Germany
You do you
I thought it was Japanese!
Ooh I like that it's little coins!
Oh god, it's salty, what the - ?
Yeah, I want to spit this out, can I spit it out?
What was that?
Black licorice bathed in sweat, that's what it is
Hey! You know what's gonna improve licorice, the world's worst candy? A s$& ton of salt
45 milligrams of sodium?!
I think it's vegemite flavored
This is the hardest thing I've ever eaten
This is something you give your friend to let them know you don't want to be friends anymore.
This German food had me going up, like I was really excited
Really running hot there and then, you lick a salty licorice and it just straight up cools you down.
We apologize, Germany
I feel a little more German, like hearty right now
I feel like I've been looking my whole entire life for meat this good, and I've never found it.